[Musik]
Ja, ich hätte gerne keine Atomwaffen,
aber ein Realist sagt, dass wir sie
für eine Weile haben werden. Atomwaffen an und für
sich sind
in ihren Konsequenzen fürchterlich, da sie kein Führer einer
Nation wirklich wollen wird  Um
diesen Knopf zu drücken Ich denke, was wir bisher über Atomwaffen gelernt haben,
ist, dass die
meisten Gesellschaften dazu tendieren,
dass sie dies tun, um ihre Souveränität zu garantieren.
Ich erwarte nicht, dass
irgendjemand sie aufgibt, bis
es einen gibt a  Ersatzkonstrukt, in
dem Sie einem Nationalstaat die Souveränität garantieren können
und zwei, dass Ihre
Nachbarn bereit sind, sich in die gleiche Richtung zu bewegen,
wie wir es bei Chemiewaffen getan haben
, und dann der letzte Punkt bei
Atomwaffen, der
mich wirklich beunruhigt, ist, dass zwei Nationen  könnten
entscheiden, dass ihre Differenzen nicht
überbrückbar sind und sie zu
Atomwaffen übergehen, aber die Konsequenz wäre für
den ganzen Planeten
Verwenden Sie sie ein wenig, dass die
Folgen hier unbekannt sind und wo
der Wendepunkt ist, der unser Klima stören würde.
Unser Ökosystem für das Leben. Eine
Atomwaffe ist einem lebenden Organismus nicht sehr unähnlich
, da sie sich ständig
ändert, dass sie lebt, dass sie
ständig ihre Fähigkeiten ändert  es ist seine
innere haltung, seine dynamik etc und
so waffen die jetzt 30 40 vielleicht sogar
50 jahre alt sind da muss man sich fragen okay
es ist halt auch arbeit und wenn es funktioniert wie
funktioniert es
wir machen uns etwas vor das wir
die auswirkungen lokalisieren können  Eine
Atomwaffe, die wahrscheinlich nicht wahr ist,
vielleicht stimmt es über die Explosion und die Hitze,
aber nicht über die anderen, die größeren
Auswirkungen auf
Sie